invité par le centre des monuments
nationaux à découvrir dit cet édifice en
france
libault fans auteur prolifique
photographe international et célèbre
blogueur chinois s'est rendu au château
d'azay-le-rideau je dorme pas d'éloges
sur la nature il est curieux de tous
niveaux femme a posé mille questions sur
l'histoire du château
sa construction sur le moyen âge aussi
tout ou presque est passé au crible
c'est un voyage dans le temps avec mes
personnages célèbres de l'histoire de
france
ibo fans a également pu admirer le
savoir-faire des compagnons charpentiers
venu au chevet du château j'ai vu la
même structure achats repas toutes ces
notes seront retranscrites sur son blog
une mine d'informations pour des
lecteurs à vis mon blog je les crée il y
a une dizaine d'années environ
un blog uniquement destinées aux voyages
il compte 1200 articles illustrés
j'ai plus de 89 millions de vu et un
demi million d'abonnés sur mon blog un
graphe
mais les fourneaux ce bloc quand on
songe que le blog de ibou fall totalise
plus de 89 millions de vues ça donne une
idée de son impact
de là à imaginer des retombées sonnantes
et trébuchantes
en termes touristiques il n'ya qu'un pas
vite franchi